i'm cj champion and i'm a professional
dunker
i perform in the best dunk contests
across the world dunk league dunk king
kings of air you name it today i've been
challenged to explain dunking in 21
levels of increasing complexity
[Music]
the things that can make a dunk really
good obviously the technicality the way
it looks the style and the air and then
how clean and how hard you finish the
dunk also how high you jump important to
note every dunker jumps completely
different they'll have their own
interpretation for this challenge level
one basic dunk
the very first steps to learn how to
jump and dunk you gotta start with
footwork so today we're gonna lower the
rim down to eight foot five this is
where most people would start i am a
left-right left-handed jumper as i
approach the rim my left foot blocks and
my right foot plants and then i jump
straight up the block foot it's the foot
that comes down first after your
penultimate step penultimate is the step
you take before you go into your jump
now that we got the footwork out of the
way let's move the rim up to 10 feet and
get some real dunks
level 2 assisted lob dunk
so this is the easiest way to land your
first dunk on a regulation size room all
you need to do is have somebody throw
the ball right in front of the rim and
you just go and get it but there's a few
things to make this work first off this
is really easy because you're able to
get a full run up approach and a full
arm swing before catching the ball and
dunking the arm swing matters it's
really important to be able to get
higher vertical jump the arm swing as
you swing your arms back and then propel
them forward the arm swing gives you
some momentum be able to just jump
higher versus having a ball on your hand
the other thing too is absorbing the
ball as the ball is coming down and your
hand is coming up you have to control
the ball your arm isn't going to be
fully straight you need to absorb it a
little bit have control and then finish
the dunk straight down into the rim to
complete this dunk you only need about
four inches over the rim if you can grab
the rim you can just about do this dunk
you don't need to know how to palm a
basketball to be able to dunk in this
case it's just keeping control of the
ball right here level three hand off
dunk
using a hand off is pretty
self-explanatory basically all you do is
you have somebody hold the ball out in
front for you and you just go get it
it's useful because you have a lot less
variables and you can have the ball
positioned in the same place every
single time you go up for a dunk
mastering a hand off dunk is crucial for
being able to experiment with more trick
dunks as we'll get to later it also
makes trick dunks a lot more consistent
level 4 off dribble dunk
off dribble dunks is mostly what you see
in basketball games this dunk is more
complex than the assisted lob dunk
because you need to have control of the
basketball being able to go into a full
approach with the basketball while
dribbling there's a few things that make
it difficult obviously you need some
coordination you need to know how to
dribble a basketball and push it out in
front of you as you're gaining speed and
going up for the approach you need to
jump higher for this one the other thing
too is your arm swing is cut what
happens is as you gather you're gonna
pump the ball straight up and as you're
coming up the other thing you have to
focus on is your offhand in my case is
my right hand you're pushing very hard
into your dunk hand in my case which is
the left hand so i'm bringing the ball
all the way up with two hands all the
way to the very top and then keeping
control of it and then finishing
straight down it's not as simple as
running up and jumping as high as you
can with the ball you have to think
about the control and the coordination
it's all about the off hand pushing into
your dunk hand a lot of times people say
i can't palm a basketball so that means
i can't dunk it that's not the case i
wasn't able to palm a basketball before
doing this dunk having your hand above
the ball just like this and having your
off hand push it into your left that's
all you need you don't need to have to
palm it you're pushing it all the way up
until you're reaching the max height and
then you're pushing the ball straight
down
level five self lob dunk this dunk
increases complexity because it requires
precision timing and control you're
throwing the ball yourself so you're
standing maybe around three point line
you throw the ball pretty high way above
the rim you let it bounce on the ground
once and that's when you run up catch it
and then finish the dunk so what makes
this difficult is the precision of the
lob if you're not a very high jumper it
has to be pretty close to the rim that
way you can you know get close and
finish the dunk you need to control the
ball into your hand if you're doing this
with one hand you have to absorb it a
little bit have good control so that way
you can bring it up to finish the dunk
timing wise your steps need to bring you
to the ball as it hits its peak when you
throw the lob you're not approaching
immediately you might have to wait a
half a second to a second before you
start your approach that way when you
jump you're gonna be reaching the ball
at its peak after the bounce level six
backboard dunk
we're increasing complexity here by
throwing the basketball off of the
backboard it coming back to you catching
it and then finishing the dunk there's a
few things that make this dunk a little
bit more difficult than a self lob the
accuracy of throwing it off the
backboard you have to get it just right
as you're approaching and throwing the
ball off of the backboard there's a lot
of things that can go wrong it can
prevent you from having the perfect
catch as you're throwing it off the
backboard your approach is already
compromised your approach might be a
little bit shorter you might stutter a
lot of times you'll see a stutter as as
they throw it off the backboard you have
to focus on throwing a good pass and as
you're doing that sometimes you might
add an extra hop into your step so it's
not going to be a very fluid motion and
when you have that halt or if you ever
have a stutter in your approach you
won't jump as high the other thing is
the catch so the ball is going to be
coming at you a lot faster a lot
speedier getting control of the ball
it's a little bit different in this case
you have to absorb a lot more which
means your arm might come back further
away from the rim a little bit more once
you have control then you have to bring
it back up straight to the rim level
seven two hand tomahawk
with this dunk we're gonna get into some
more trick dunks so a tip that most
people might not think about when
attempting this dunk after your jump
you're gonna pump the ball straight up
as if you're just gonna do a two-hand
dunk but as soon as you come straight up
then that's when you bring the ball it's
not a one full swinging motion basically
like going into a standard two-hand dunk
first but then you're bringing it back
into a two-hand tomahawk and then finish
the jump there is an unspoken threshold
of what a tomahawk is when i say
threshold it's how far back you bring
the ball most of us dunkers will say
there's an invisible lion we just want
the ball to come back here basically if
the ball doesn't come near that far back
that's a baby tomahawk it's not a real
tomahawk level 8 windmill dunk
we're increasing complexity here because
there's a lot more travel that the ball
needs to do to complete this dunk what
happens is after you pump up you're
going to swing the ball in a swinging
motion
all the way down and all the way back up
just like a windmill the key thing that
you need to focus on here is your off
hand my right hand as i pump up it's
gonna be pushing very hard into my left
hand all the way through the motion and
i'm not stopping the push just at the
very bottom of the motion i'm bringing
it back up with two hands and then i'm
letting go at the top and then finishing
with my left hand level nine 360 dunk
we're increasing complexity with this
dunk because you're not actually always
looking at the rim so twisting in the
air can actually be
disorienting especially for me as a more
hip dominant jumper who needs more speed
into the dunk the more speed you get
into a 360
the more
things that can go off for example i
might be tilted in the air like that and
that makes finishing the dunk a bit
harder when i cover distance on a 360
there's a small window to hit this dunk
because you're passing the rim so you
have to spin find the rim and finish
versus somebody who's more knee dominant
they're able to come a bit slower
they're able to jump more straight up
and down without covering too much
distance and that makes their window to
finish a dunk a lot larger level 10 push
off windmill
a lot of times in dunk competitions you
will see somebody being set up as a prop
for a dunk if you see that ball being
placed on their head or on their neck
that's going to be a push-off duck so
this is a big controversy in the dunk
world right now when you see a dunk like
this you might think wow that looks
amazing most of the time in contests
this gets really high scores
but it's called push off windmill
because what you're doing you're pushing
off of their head you're pushing the
ball straight down into your head
getting a bit of a boost kind of like
leap frog this can add maybe four inches
to your vert people get away with it
because if you're a high jumper it's
almost invisible it's not very easy to
see there is one thing that does make
this kind of difficult is you're
actually jumping over somebody that
could be a mental block in itself this
isn't just a physical dunk it is a
mental duck it does require a good
amount of confidence the good thing
about push-off dunks is it does open the
door for very highly technical dunks
later on that we'll get into now that we
understand push off dunks we can
increase complexity by doing a backwards
dunk level 11 double up x
with the double up x what's happening
here you're getting hands on the ball
pretty quickly and then you're gonna be
pushing straight down giving you that
extra boost and without looking at the
rim you're just gonna finish two hands
backwards now that we've learned the
reverse dunk we're gonna increase the
complexity by basically doing the same
dunk but without a push off level 12
reverse pump
it may look
easier but i'll tell you it's really not
coming off the dribble you're going to
be coming at the rim at an angle and
then basically as you jump your back is
almost going to be facing the rim you're
going to pump the ball straight up and
you want to bring the ball with straight
arms straight back down and again
there's another threshold that you want
to pass you want to get the ball down
between your legs as you're bringing
your legs up and then you have to bring
the ball straight back again and finish
the dunk you're moving the ball against
your momentum so it does require a good
amount of physicality this is a pretty
stylish dunk the higher you jump and the
longer you hold that pose the cooler it
looks level 13 two-hand reverse windmill
we're increasing complexity here by
combining two ducks that we've already
done we have the reverse pump and the
windmill this is one of those dunks that
requires a good amount of physicality on
takeoff i like to have my right shoulder
facing the rim so as i'm jumping my
whole body is rotated maybe 45 to 90
degrees away from the rim and i pump
straight up after the pump it's a
swinging motion like a windmill but
you're doing this with two hands and as
you're doing that you're rotating your
body a little bit more so your back is
facing the rim then you're bringing the
ball straight back up with two hands
finishing backwards having to twist your
body in midair with this dunk does
require a good amount of effort and it
does use up every muscle in your body
level 14 east bay
also known as the between the legs dunk
this is a pretty big milestone dunk i
think any hooper basketball player they
want to be able to do this dunk so to
land a two foot east bay it's almost
like the ball path is the same ball path
as a windmill but what you need to do in
my case is i have to lift up my block
foot which is my left leg so i'm in the
air and i bring the ball down with one
hand lift up my left leg and the ball
has to go between or underneath my
hamstring over into my left hand and
then finish the dunk with my left hand
the few things that make this dunk
difficult is the transfer and also being
able to jump high enough you do need a
good amount of vert to be able to land
this dunk what you have to do again with
that right hand you're off hand you're
pumping up with the ball into your right
hand and then you're pushing as hard as
you can through and underneath your
hamstring and once it's all the way
through you have to locate the rim and
finish up the rim another thing to focus
on is hand placement as you come up with
the ball my right hand being my offhand
as i pump the ball my hand is going to
be almost on top of the ball that way i
can start the swinging motion really
quick versus if you pump the ball like
this then you'll have to rotate your
hand over the ball and then start
swinging through level 15 behind the
back dunk the complexity increases here
because of the transfer is very
difficult for a lot of people this is a
pretty technical dunk the travel
distance of the basketball is pretty
long here making it pretty difficult to
get this dunk done right with the
transfer it's all about hand positioning
again what happens with this dunk is as
you pump straight up you're gonna bring
the ball around behind your back collect
it with your dunk hand and then bring it
back up to the rim and finish the dunk
everybody messes up this transfer
because it's difficult trying to get it
into your dunk hand and bring it up to
the rim so what you need to do is it's
all about hand placement as you're
transferring as you're pushing from your
right hand over into your left once you
collect the ball you want your hand
almost underneath the basketball that
way when you push up into this hand
you're able to have more control as you
bring the ball up versus a lot of people
tend to have their hand way on top of
the ball and you don't have enough
strength to bring the ball from your off
hand into your dominant hand and bring
it all the way up with this hand
placement it is difficult to bring the
ball up against your momentum as you're
coming straight up level 16 double up
the double up dunk invented by t-dub is
when you go between the legs over
somebody the t-dub version he's not
using a push-off he's having somebody
hold the ball straight up the version
i'm doing here is more consistent
because i am using a push off as you see
the ball is on his head i'm just doing
this for more consistency as you
approach your prop or the guy that's
holding the ball you really want to
quickly get your hand on top of the ball
pushing down and then getting through
what you have to also consider too is
you're jumping over somebody so you want
to clear them so you're thinking about
clearing somebody putting the ball
between your legs getting a good control
on your dunk hand and then finishing at
the rim level 17 reverse 360 windmill
with this dunk we are increasing
complexity because as we're twisting
we're going against the grain we're
going against your momentum as you're
spinning with this dunk we are combining
a 360 and we are combining a windmill
you do need the perfect balance of speed
on your approach to get this done for me
what i need to do here is actually cut
my approach by about one step that
allows me to go a little bit slower and
the slower i go the more straight up and
down i can be as i do this dunk the only
thing is it cuts my vertical so i don't
jump as high that's what makes this dunk
difficult
level 18 the slingshot
the aim here is to jump and with your
off hand swing the ball way across your
body into your dunk hand and hold that
position with the ball in one arm and
then you have to come all the way across
your body again with as much force as
you can to bring it toward the rim so
with swinging dunks like a windmill or
two-hand reverse windmill dunk the ball
path provides momentum with this dunk
specifically you're relying purely on
the physicality of your core shoulders
and arm bringing the ball straight back
and straight forward level 19 the
honeydew
with this dunk i'm going to be dunking
my entire forearm in my case i'm
actually jumping over somebody here and
then putting my entire forearm into the
rim and hanging see it's important that
you hang if you just put your elbow in
and slide out i don't call that a honey
dip dunk of all the dunks that i can do
i believe this one is the most dangerous
i feel like you can really hurt yourself
i've hurt myself in the past level 20
the scorpion
so the scorpion dunk is one of the most
unique dunks out there we're increasing
complexity here by using extreme
physicality to swing the ball down and
back around up toward the rim finishing
blind with one arm the variation that i
show here is actually called the cuff
scorpion so i'm not jumping over
somebody it's with a cup you have to
sweep the ball down before you bring it
back up a lot of the times what happens
is people will swing the ball straight
up toward the rim instead of using a
sweeping down motion and that's not a
true scorpion these days dunkers they're
really pushing the limits on what is and
isn't possible there's a lot of
combinations of
these foundational dunks that i've
listed like 360 e-space and you can get
into crazy things like the crown the
kamikaze the hide-and-seek the lost and
found the possibilities are endless
there's actually thousands maybe 10
thousands of dunks that are out there
all with varying levels of complexity we
covered a lot of things today that i
hope gives you a better understanding of
the complex world of dunking
[Music]
bye